[Aplausos]
yo nací en león hace no mucho tiempo y
cuando era pequeña mi padre me llevaba
todos los domingos a casa de una señora
que tenía un pañuelo negro que ataba
aquí con un doble nudo tenía una ceja
que le recorría la frente de lado a lado
tenía una nariz ganchuda con una verruga
con tres pelos tenía una barbilla picuda
con tres pelos blancos más que cuando te
viste de sabaté pinchada y tenían unos
dedos largos largos largos y las manos
siempre muy frías y cuando te caricia
acariciaba tus sentías lagartijas que te
recorrían el cuerpo y mi padre me
llevaba todos los domingos a ver a esta
señora sabéis quién era yo era una bruja
que seguro que eso qué estáis pensando
era mi abuela
y mi abuela nunca me contó un cuento mi
abuela era maragata de un pueblecito
cerquita de astorga y vivió en una época
en que la gente tenía miedo y cuando la
gente tiene miedo guarda silencio calla
yo me empeñaba en que mi abuela me
contara algún cuento y le decía abuela
cuéntame un cuento pero mi abuela nada
así que a mí me tocó aprender a escuchar
el silencio y querer a la gente que no
tiene voz y que no cuenta pero que
cuenta más que nadie y fue así como me
tocó aprender a leer para escuchar los
cuentos que mi abuela no me contaba y
leí tanto que acabé la universidad me
dice filóloga y experta en tradiciones
orales y pasó el tiempo y después acabé
se una narradora y editora y me dedico a
todo eso conjuntamente ahora yo cuento
para que la gente como mi abuela que no
tiene voz la tenga cuento para que esta
gente que no cuenta pero que cuentan más
que nadie puedan contar sin miedo esta
gente que no tiene literatura sino
folclore que no tiene arte sino
artesanía y que no tienen religiones
supersticiones pero que son la inmensa
mayoría de las personas que pueblan este
mundo y este oficio de escuchar a gente
que no tiene voz a gente que no importa
gente insignificante a gente anónima me
llevo como bien decía ernesto a
mozambique y allí en un lugar que se
abaja cumaná donde llegan los niños que
viven en la calle por la mañana y les
entregan un trozo de pan y leche en
polvo con agua caliente conocí a un niño
a un niño de meego va un niño de 4 años
un niño que vive en la calle y se empeñó
en contarme un cuento a pesar de que yo
iba a escuchar a otra gente y me sentí a
escucharle y me contó el siguiente
cuento
había una vez un gatito que una buena
mañana salió de su casa como ama gatita
y papá gatito y se encontró con los
hombres verdes con los hombres que
tienen fusil y dispararon a mamá gatita
y a papá gatito y le preguntaron a
gatito pequeño donde vivía abuela gatito
y gatito pequeño pensó que los hombres
verdes los hombres con fusil
querían jugar a la guerra y los llevó al
lugar donde vive abuela abuela gatito y
los hombres verdes dispararon a abuela
gatito y también al abuelo gatito y al
tío del gatito y gatito se ha quedado
solo menos mal que ha encontrado un
lugar por donde donde las mañanas le dan
leche caliente contamos cuentos para que
la gente silenciada como mi abuela y
para que la gente insignificante como
denegaba tengan voz
yo además de escribir también como les
decía soy narradora oral y mi nombre de
contar es ana griott
y este nombre que en principio no elegí
sino que me eligió porque mi grupo de
narradores se llamaba criado y empezaron
a llamarme a nahla de crío y con ana
griott me quedé pues este nombre griot
designa es un nombre común que designa a
los narradores del centro oeste de
áfrica y tienen un origen mítico y es
que cuentan que en el norte de senegal
en un pueblo sucedió algo prodigioso y
es que en este pueblo se murió un señor
que fijaos que esto puede no parecer
prodigioso porque nos morimos todos pero
es que este señor en senegal se murió
con una tremenda erección
y claro esto provoca problemas vecinales
porque si tú en tierra son señor con
erección se le queda la elección fuera
y si algún vecino o pizza pues entonces
ya hay disputas entre los vecinos así
que el jefe de la tribu le pidió a la
primera esposa que redujera a que el
problema
y para ello la primera esposa del finado
yacía con el finado y se quedó
embarazada y parió un niño que nada más
de hacer se reveló como un ser dotado
con el don de la palabra a que el niño
nada más de hacer contaba cuentos como
era hijo de un muerto sabía las
historias de los que ya no están sobre
la tierra y las traía a los que todavía
estamos sobre la tierra para que no nos
olvidemos de quiénes somos para que no
nos olvidemos de a dónde vamos y para
que no nos olvidemos de dónde venimos
así cuentan en el norte de senegal cuál
es la función de los que contamos
cuentos mantener viva la memoria de los
que ya no están
contamos para muchísimas otras cosas
también contamos porque los cuentos
construye en una casa de palabras un
lugar donde los niños se sientan seguros
cada vez que un padre se sienta al lado
de un niño y comienza había una vez y le
cuenta un cuento está construyendo un
lugar seguro donde su hijo va a
encontrar refugio estos cuentos llenos
de repeticiones llenos de símbolos
porque los cuentos están llenos de
símbolos los cuentos no hablan de la
realidad hablan de la verdad el dramón
no existe en la realidad pero existe en
la verdad porque lo que existe es el
miedo a ese poder devastador que tiene
el fuego de esto hablan los cuentos de
la verdad los cuentos hablan de la
confianza en los otros porque todos los
cuentos estos cuentos tradicionales que
se llaman así por que perviven en
variantes porque son diferentes en
función de la persona que los cuenta
porque cada vez que uno cuenta un cuento
le pone su piel su calor su pálpito y su
aliento estos cuentos tradicionales
cuentan siempre lo mismo hay un
personaje que tiene un conflicto
se pone en camino y en el camino se
encuentra con el otro con el otro con el
donante que diría a vladimir propp y en
ese encuentro con el otro consigue
resolver el problema que lo ha puesto en
camino el conflicto y regresa al lugar
del que ha partido convertido en
soberano en dueño de su propia vida con
todo lo que ha aprendido estos cuentos
hablan de que el otro no es el que te
asesina el que te mata el que te quita
la esposa o la plaza de la guardería
sino que el otro es el que te ayuda
gracias a esta capacidad de confiar en
el otro el ser humano comenzó a tejer
estas redes de lo colectivo y gracias a
la fuerza de lo colectivo el ser humano
se perpetuó en la cadena evolutiva
frente a otros mamíferos mucho más
poderosos que el hombre la primera vez
que tuve un trabajo remunerado fue una
residencia de mayores y me contrataron
para contar cuentos yo llegaba allí y
empezaba a contar cuentos y contaba
utilizar una técnica que era dejar a los
abuelos con un cuento inconcluso la
técnica del cuento inconcluso llegaba
contaba un cuento
y cuando el cuento estaba en el clima
esencia hay lo siento pero me tengo que
ir mañana vuelvo al día siguiente
regresaba acababa ese cuento y comenzaba
un cuento que acababa el día siguiente y
así iba teniendo a mi clientela
fidelizada esto del cuento inconcluso es
la técnica de los hack a but it's sirios
los narradores que cuentan lo contaban
en la siria pacificada la primera vez
como les decía llega a las 8 de la tarde
me senté con de un cuento contigo cuento
para que vieran que yo sabía contar el
segundo que conté lo dejé inconcluso y
dije mañana vuelvo y les conté un cuento
erótico
al día siguiente cuando llegue estaban
con los andadores en el hall que
convocaba al puerto un momento ella voy
bueno no os podéis imaginar cómo estaban
de interesados al cabo de tres meses la
directora de la residencia municipal me
llamó a su despacho
yo llegué y me sorprendió mucho que
tuvieran alguna queja porque estaban
súper fidelizados y entonces me contó
que había venido un técnico municipal a
hacer una pirámide de población y desde
hacía tres meses que yo trabajaba allí
había descendido la curva de la
mortalidad vertiginosamente claro como
te mueres sin saber cómo acaba un cuento
te esperas al día siguiente y si al día
siguiente te dejan con el cuento a
medias pues no te mueres yo dije que
bien no y me dijo que mal somos una
residencia municipal y necesitamos las
plazas
así que me despidieron pero yo aprendí
de una que esto de los cuentos es para
vivir yo quería irme sin contarles que
hubo un dictador llamado stalin que como
todos los dictadores utilizó el imperio
del miedo para someter a la gente y creó
unos campos de exterminio que se
llamaron los gulag ahí en siberia la
gente era condenada por no pensar lo
mismo que el dictador a trabajos
forzados con muy poca comida y con muy
poca tepic a baja temperatura y casi
todos morían pero cuentan que en este
lugar cuando sonaba la sirena que
anunciaba el toque de queda
una mujer se sentaba en una litera y
comenzaba a contar había una vez no
sabemos si la mujer era de astorga de
áfrica o de dónde pero contaba un cuento
y durante el momento del cuento la gente
que vivía allí hacinada en aquel
barracón en aquel bula esperando la
muerte tenía la certeza de que otros
mundos eran posibles los mundos que
vivían en los labios de la narradora y
gracias a esta certeza mantenían la
esperanza y gracias a ello conservaban
la vida
cuentan que esta narradora enfermo y que
la gente de su barracón hacía parte de
su trabajo y le daba parte de su comida
porque todos sabían que de la
pervivencia de los cuentos de la
literatura de la cultura de todo eso que
nos recortan impunemente depende nuestra
propia vida porque todos sabían lo mismo
que los ancianos de mi residencia de
mayores que esto de los cuentos es para
vivir
[Aplausos]